hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a pretty fun problem
construct a binary tree from a pre-order
and in order traversal so we're actually
given
two integer arrays representing one
the pre-order traversal and two the
in-order traversal
of a binary tree and our
goal is to take these two traversals
and the orderings of those nodes and
then can
reconstruct basically the original
binary tree
that the traversals are from and it is
technically possible
these two traversals have all the
information we need
we just need to take that information
and then deconstruct it
and then reconstruct this binary tree
from those so just to verify it let's go
through this
tree and actually do the pre-order
traversal first of all so
first we know pre-order traversal is you
start at the root and then you process
the current node
then you do the left subtree then you do
the right subtree right
so let's just let's just do the
pre-order traversal so we're starting at
the root we
do the root node first that's how
pre-order works so then we get a three
next we're going to go to the left sub
tree and then
and then do pre-order traversal on that
left subtree
we see nine right so we're going to add
nine to our
pre-order traversal and it doesn't have
any children so we're actually done with
nine we're done with three now it's time
to do the right subtree
in pre-order traversal so we start at 20
add
20 to our pre-order
go left we see 15 add 15 to the
pre-order
15 doesn't have any children now we go
to the right
subtree seven so add seven it's our last
node
to the pre-order traversal right and
this actually take a look at this take a
look at all the values it matches
exactly
with the input so this is the uh
pre-order traversal now let's just
validate the in-order traversal
as well inorder traversal is we start at
the
root right we take care of the entire
left subtree first then we take care of
the root node
and then we take care of the right
subtree with
in order traversal that's the general
order so let's validate
the inorder traversal of this tree so
we're starting
at one we're we're starting at the root
three but we're not going to add three
yet first we're gonna do the left
subtree
we see we have a nine the nine does not
have any left or right children so now
we can add that nine
to our inorder traversal remember we're
doing this in order
left to right we go back up to the root
now we can process the root we can take
three and add it to the inorder
traversal
and now we're going to do the entire
right subtree
so we get to 20 but we're not we're
going to wait for 20. we're going to
first do the left
subtree 15 15 is the only value here so
it doesn't have any children add 15 to
the inorder traversal
now we can add 20 because we've done the
left subtree
20 is added and then last we go to the
right subtree
only one value seven let's add that
seven to
our in order now let's take a look at
these
five values notice how they are the
exact same
five values in the exact same order as
that in-order traversal that we were
given
so we can see that the
that what they gave us was correct but
now the question remains how can we
actually take
these two uh arrays these two
traversals and construct this tree well
it's definitely possible
let me show you how to do that right now
so i just want to let you know that
there's actually
two things two main facts that we're
going to be using to construct this tree
so the first
fact is that the first value
in pre-order traversal is always going
to be the
root right we remember when we do
pre-order traversal right
we're always processing the root first
so if i was taking
the pre-order traversal that we're given
right we we
remember this is the pre-order traversal
that we're given the
first value in pre-order traversal is
always going to be the root so
this is the first value three it's
guaranteed
to be the root because that's how
pre-order traversal works the first
value
in pre-order traversal is always the
root node now we don't know about the
rest of these
right but we can recursively
construct now the left subtree and the
right subtree right we can
we can we're done with this three right
now our goal is to reconstruct the left
subtree
hey lucky for us the first value here
is always going to be the root of
the of the left subtree right because
that's how pre-order traversal works
right
so that's one thing that we're going to
use the first value is
always going to be the root and then we
can take the sub
list right we can remove the three we
don't need to look at it anymore then we
take the sub list and then
basically we're going to do this
recursively that's what i'm telling you
okay we can construct the root but we
need more information than that right
and then we're let's say we're done
looking at this three now i want to take
this uh array right and i want to know
which values are going to go in the left
subtree and which are going to go on the
right subtree
from looking at the actual tree itself
we know the answer right we know that
this is where we're going to cut our
list right
the 9 is going in the left subtree
right these three values are going in
the right subtree but how can we
determine that
well that's what we need our inorder
traversal array for
okay so now let's take a look at the
input array we're given for the inorder
traversal and by the way let me just
mention that
every value in the traversal is
guaranteed to be unique
that's true for both of the traversals
the inorder and the pre-order every
value is going to be unique because
every value in the tree
is going to be unique but okay so far we
know that this first
value three is gonna be the root right
so now let's
find three right we we know three is the
root right
so we removed it from our first list
basically right
but now let's find it in our in
order list we find it's right over here
3 is in this index right so we know we
don't need this 3 anymore right we
already created that
node but so now what does
this in order array tell us
notice how this is convenient for us
every
value to the left of the 3 that we just
created the root from
every value over here which is only 9 is
going to
go in the left subtree and every value
to the
right of 3 is going to go in the right
subtree that's
really convenient for us why is this the
case because that's
basically the purpose of in-order
traversal right
it guarantees that we're going to go
through the tree in order right from
left to right basically right so if we
see the three here
and that's and this is the position in
the array we know everything
here is going to be in the left sub tree
everything here is going to be in the
right subtree that's what it tells us
this is really convenient for us because
we can count it right we can see there's
exactly
one value that's going to go in the
left subtree and there's exactly three
values that are going to go in the right
subtree so what we can do
is we can take we can take the remainder
of the pre-order
array and then partition it right
partition it over here because we know
one value is going to go in the left
subtree and three
values are going to go in the right
subtree so that's what we're doing and
we're going to continue this right
so now let's recur and by the way in the
code we're going to do this recursively
let's create the left subtree
we know that okay this is the in
order portion right and this is how
we're gonna partition
it from pre-order right we see this is
the array to create the left subtree the
thing here is
notice how this is size one right
there's only one value here and there's
only one value here right that tells us
that the sub tree we're creating is only
gonna have one node in it right so
nine is the only node in the left
subtree so we're going to create that
node put the value there and now we're
basically
done with this left sub tree obviously
because there's no more
uh you know there's no more nodes left
in this general area right this these
values are reserved
for the right subtree this is reserved
for the right subtree
okay so now we're looking at the
pre-order portion right there's three
values just like in the in order portion
and remember how are we gonna create the
root node of this subtree now we always
take the first value in pre-order
traversal it's
20 right the value is 20 so we're going
to take this
value 20. we don't need it anymore
because we're going to create a
a node from that value and so now we
need to know which values are going to
go in the left sub tree and which are
going to go
in the right subtree we know by finding
20 right 20 is the value let's find 20
in our in order traversal it's over here
by the way in the code i'm going to be
calling the index of this
mid so m for mid we find the
index of 20 right we know we don't need
20 anymore so we can get rid of it right
we see that there's one value on the
left of 20
and there's one value on the right of
20.
this tells us that one value is going to
go in the left subtree and one value is
going to go in the right subtree right
just like we have over here
so now let's construct that left subtree
we know it's going to be exactly size 1
from looking over here so we take this
right where can we now our job is to
recursively create the left subtree
we're going to take this 15 since it's
the first value in the subarray for
pre-order right we know that it's going
to be the root of
the current subtree we're at so let's
get rid of this this 15.
let's create that node right 15 over
here is going to be a node
and there's no more values left in this
subtree because we know it's only going
to be size
1. okay now we're creating the right
subtree
we know that there's only one value in
the right subtree from looking over here
with and since there's only one value
left in general it's a seven
we can make a node from it and then
we're done
we know we're done because we've
basically gotten rid of every single
value
in our arrays pre-order and in order
so using these two arrays we were able
to create our
tree correctly and just let me just
summarize what we're actually doing
we're not doing a lot
we don't need a ton of information
remember
the first value in pre-order
the pre-order array is always going to
be the root right that's just how it
works and then once we
take that value create a node from it
and then when we try to
look that value up in in order traversal
right
then we can get some subarrays
right we can take we can take the length
of the left
and right sub array so the right sub
array is three
and the left sub array is one note
now these counts one and three they tell
us
how to partition the pre-order traversal
so take a look at the pre-order
traversal
one tells us that we're gonna cut over
here because this needs to be size
one this needs to be size three
and then from this subarray this
subarray with only one value
we are going to recursively run the
algorithm
to create this left subtree and with
this sub array we're going to
recursively run the algorithm
to create this subtree and we're just
going to continuously repeat that
process until we get to our base cases
and until we're finished with every
single node that we need to create
so now let me actually show you the code
it's actually very short
less than 10 lines okay so as i
mentioned this is a recursive algorithm
so we always want to start with the base
case and the base case is going to be
what if we don't have any nodes
to traverse through the two arrays that
we're given
that means we can return null or
basically we don't have to create
a tree so if pre-order is empty or
in order is empty then we can return
null we have no values so we don't need
to create a tree we can return null
otherwise we're going to create a tree
node right
and what's the value of that tree node
going to be well it's going to be
the first value that happens to be in
the pre-order
array just like i showed you right
always going to be the first value so
it's always going to be
index of zero and then whatever that
value was
we want to find the position of it in
the in order array so inorder dot
index so we want the index of that value
pre-order of zero
and we're going to get it in mid now
this is the part
where we're going to build the subtree
so root.left let's create the left
subtree and we're going to do this
recursively as i mentioned
so self.build tree we're calling the
function that we're
inside of and the convenient part about
python is we can do
sublist so that's going to cut down our
code quite a bit so we need to pass in
the new
pre-order and in order arrays or the
sub-arrays more likely so pre-order
what are we going to pass in for the
left subtree of
pre-order well mid tells us
mid tells us how many nodes we want the
index
of basically the value of mid tells us
how many nodes we want in the left
subtree so what i'm going to do is for
pre-order
we're going to start at index one we're
basically skipping the zero index
because we already just created a node
for the zero index we're starting at
index one going all the way
up until mid plus one in python
this mid plus one is non-inclusive so
this sub array is really just
a pre-order from index one to mid so
that's what we're doing and we're going
to pass in the in
order portion that we need as well and
that's just going to be
from the beginning up until mid but not
including mid right
this probably makes more sense if you go
back and look at the picture but
basically we're just creating the
appropriate sub-lists
that we need to create the left subtree
we're going to do basically the exact
same thing with the
right subtree and i would encourage you
to draw this out
yourself to basically reinforce what
you're learning or
watching me do right now so to build the
right subtree
we need every value after this sub list
right so we can just say starting at
index
mid plus one going until the end
of the list that's how you do it in
python we're starting at mid plus one
and going until the end of that
sub list just like i showed in the
picture and
for in order we can actually do the
exact same thing
we want every node to the right of
mid in in order right from our inorder
array we want every value to the right
of this
index mid so we can do that with mid
plus one start starting at mid plus one
and then going until the end of the
array so now let me close this function
and so this is literally all you have to
do the reason it's so easy
is mainly because i'm using python but
you could you could
read you could do this code without
python it would probably just be a
couple extra lines
you might need to pass in a couple extra
parameters into this build tree function
basically just these indices that i'm
doing you might not be able to create
sub lists
but you can at least create you can at
least pass these indices into your
functions
in java and other languages so with that
we have actually created our
uh tree so the only thing left for us to
do is return that tree
so with that being said this is the
final solution it's probably
less code than you would have predicted
but the problem is a little tricky
but it's kind of enjoyable at least in
my opinion
so i hope that this was helpful if you
enjoyed please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon